Speaker 1: One of the things I've been saying
during this pseudo scandal involving Republican
Congresswoman Liz Cheney is that we should
not forget who Liz Cheney is.
Liz Cheney is nothing more than a Republican
with whom I disagree on basically every relevant
policy question.
And she happens to correctly believe that
Joe Biden won the election and it shouldn't
be a controversial belief that is it.
And it's been disappointing to see even some
on the supposed left talk about we should
stand with Liz Cheney, stand with her for
what Republicans want a stripper of her leadership
role as they did.
Let them figure it out.
I don't care to defend Liz Cheney one way
or the other.
Sure.
It's funny.
It's curious to see the incredible double
standard where the right claims to oppose
so-called cancelation.
And yet they canceled Liz Cheney's leadership
position for something that should be uncontroversial,
which is Trump.
Trump really lost the election.
That's it.
But I have no interest in defending Liz Cheney
or standing with Liz Cheney.
And case in point, she was interviewed by
Fox News's Bret Baier late last week.
And on one issue, the 2020 election results,
she did a really great thing.
She told Fox News host Bret Bair.
Your network has to tell the truth about this
issue.
Bret Bair didn't like it.
Lots of people did that.
A Republican went on FOX News and said, you
need to tell the truth about the election.
Let's take a look.
Speaker 3: And then I continued to say it,
though, when I say in principle, it's because
people of Winogrand
Speaker 2: who are electing a congressperson
to fight for them and to fight against the
Biden agenda.
Why wouldn't they say, is this the person
that's going to get it done?
Because your colleagues
Speaker 3: are.
I'm going to I'm going to answer the question.
We all have an obligation and I would say
Fox News, especially, especially Fox News,
has a particular obligation to make sure people
know the election wasn't stolen.
Fox News, FOX News.
Bret, I'm going to answer your question.
Fox News needs to make sure that if you're
FOX News, you have to make sure that the American
people.
Bret, you're doing the interview.
I'm answering the question, Congressman.
We need to make sure that the American people
recognize and understand that the election
wasn't stolen, that we shouldn't perpetuate
the big lie and that there's real danger.
You know, I've worked in countries around
the world.
Speaker 1: OK, so it's great, right?
I mean, I agree.
That's great seeing a Republican do that on
Fox News.
That's great stuff.
But then and this is the bigger point, Bret
Bair asks Liz Cheney, did you vote for Joe
Biden?
She's so anti Trump.
Did you vote for Joe Biden?
And she says not only did she not vote for
Joe Biden against Trump, she would never vote
for any Democrat, period.
Doesn't matter who it is.
Take a look.
Speaker 3: And we are going to abide by the
rule of law.
Speaker 2: Do you believe that America is
better off with President Biden than President
Trump?
Speaker 3: I believe that President Trump's
policies, which I supported 93 percent of
the time, were much better for America.
Now, that isn't the issue, though.
The issue is whether or not we abide by the
rule of law.
Did you for what I did not whether and I would
not and I would not vote for a Democrat ever.
Speaker 1: Do not forget who Liz Cheney is.
Her depraved, immoral party of which she's
a proud member.
Did her wrong.
OK, they can figure it out.
We're not standing with her or them.
She may be anti the former guy, anti Trump,
but she's still a right winger and a radical
one.
Is that as left as I am?
I would never make a proactive, preemptive
blanket statement.
Like I would never vote for a Republican.
If you give me a specific race and the Republican
is better than the Democratic option, then
I'd vote for the Republican.
It's that simple.
The fact that she's making such a statement
with no caveats about the quality of the Republican
and the quality of the Democrat really shows
us what we should have already known, which
is Liz Cheney is no different than the Trump
McCarthy wing of the party with some slightly
different beliefs.
But remember, she voted with Trump.
What was it?
Ninety two percent of the time, something
like that.
She's burning a bridge that's already on fire.
And we shouldn't see it as a particularly
brave move or anything like it.
I don't take sides in the Trump and Civil
War.
It's bad for them.
Let the war rage.
I have no interest in defending anybody on
either side of it.
Mitt Romney, anti Trump Republican, didn't
vote for Trump, marched with Black Lives Matter.
OK, he was asked.
OK, Mr. Mr. Romney, sir, now that Biden's
president, what next?
And he said his priority is preventing tax
increases and preventing socialism.
These are not our friends, and it's important
not to be tricked into thinking they are.
Liz Cheney has been silent on the voter suppression
bills that have been spreading nationally.
She's doing nothing to speak out against it.
She just doesn't believe that Trump won.
She doesn't believe that lie.
It's not heroic.
And this is why Liz Cheney shouldn't be lionized
just for being one Republican willing to tell
one simple truth.
At the end of the day, she doesn't really
want anything to change.
And you heard it from her, she would never
vote for any Democrat, period